[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de nous faire aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui on va faire des
jambonneaux en petit 1 pour les une
potée de jambonneau au maïs devient et
une salade de facteurs aux petits
légumes
tout ça me paraît bien simple est il n'y
aura pas d'armagnac aujourd'hui le droit
de 20 c'est un menu tranquille
tranquille mais délicieux quand même et
facile à faire et facile à faire et
relativement économique bien le team a
si peu coûteux parce que voilà quand
même ce pas cher non alors qu'est ce
qu'il vous faut pour ces deux recettes
il nous faut du seul rires des carottes
des poivrons de deux sortes siona la
chance de l'avoir de l'oignon du laurier
du terme doit être par là le voilà de la
ciboulette du maïs a sa statue originale
faire qu'on annonce surtout en amérique
- chez nous mais généralement je vais
quand même essayé pas mal et moi il y en
a besoin connais pas moins pas trop vous
devenez un peu internationale rassemble
pour les poulets mais il y en a qui se
régale avec sa bombe après du persil du
poireau des navets delà de l'estragon
des petits oignons quand on a la chance
dans la voix bien entendu un chou et
deux petits jambonneau deux petits
jambonneau mammites et je les trouve
très jolie bien ils sont très jolies on
en mange pas assez souvent parce que
c'est délicieux gens vont nous et c'est
un petit goût très fin il vole et ça les
deux trois jours
c'est excellent et c'est une grande
tradition de notre pays dans la nuit
suivant vieille recette de france
charbonneau et bien alors les nouvelles
sont un peu spéciales
ah oui mais c'est des logisticiennes
salah de ça on dirait des tuyaux la mire
et les pays occupés en biseau elles sont
exprès pour faire ça et là quelques
éléments alors qu'est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de faire en premier on va
commencer par la potée de jambonneau
maïs comment faites vous je vais
blanchir le chou oui d'abord ça les sort
un petit peu de goût un peu amer où il
joue comme ça c'est mieux je vais couper
en quatre oui parce que c'est pour 4 et
blanches et bien entendu c'est de l'eau
un peu salée pas trop salée pas pour soi
mais là on n'y vais pas c'est le
blanchir et ses parents ne sait pas le
cuir
c'est pas le cuir voilà
et pendant que il va blanchir oui
dans une autre casserole je vois que
vous avez dû mettre de l'eau
probablement
j'avais de l'eau elle laissa libre je
vais le faire voilà alors en scène
gentiment papa parce qu'à force de cuir
ça va réduire
oui mais votre jambon aulas vous appelez
ça comment jugez-vous jarry gérer en cas
de jouer quinze jours demain jour de
manoeuvres de beau frère il se trouve
qu'ils les feraient passer quelques fois
on a fait ça lisieux l'avait traîné si
vous l'achetez salée pour le
puis c'est tout mais celui-là il est
frais alors on va bien a rebaptisé l'eau
voilà alors du poisson on va y mettre le
bouquet garni persil thym laurier
ça va 2 voilà les navets enfin ils m'ont
tout ce qui est plus long en cuir mais
les carottes et puis le pauvre lui
mettrai dans ce petit moment on va
mettre que l'oignon et l'onu introduire
à voir maintenant si marseille en a
c'est oui voilà on va la laisser un
petit peu vous dire comme ça et c'est
tout pour le moment on va attendre avant
de rajouter là-dessus et après on
rajoutera dans un petit moment la suite
quand de chou aura blanchi on c'est bon
c'est bon pour apprendre de ça suffit
vous croyez oui la limite tout il y
avait quatre personnes
il faut prendre là vous prendre un
programme pour eux chez vous nous ici on
veut que la vérité optimiste adresse que
tout rentre là voilà on va laisser
bouillir un petit peu ça ça va bien
donner du goût parce qu'il faut que le
terme agents prennent bien le pare feu
vient de vous et maintenant maïté ça
vous paraît le moment d'ajouter le
poireau peut-être le jouet a bien changé
et voilà on va dire du tout le poireau
on parle m tout parce qu'avec ce trophée
petit voilà parce que ça va diminuer
vous inquiétez pas et bien sûr et les
rachats maïs vous mettez comme n'en
voulaient plus y ait un peu oui on va
enlever mais enlevez les feuilles lui
enlever les poils
voilà quand nous étions en a mangé
annonce est pas de même en a dans les
jambes
pas du tout
c'est relativement récent non moi j'ai
mal je me souviens pendant la guerre les
allemands des prisonniers en marge et
vous mes panneaux on n'avait rien à
manger alors vous manger quand même le
nigeria rien
est ce qu'il y avait et ben oui voilà
une culture nouvelle série de culte et
de l'ovaire et qui marche très très bien
voilà et b tout y est on va remettre le
couvercle et on va laisser cuire ça
vient une heure une heure et demie on va
le surveiller
alors on va préparer la salade la salade
de pâtes heures c'est un plat chaud ou
froid à 9.3 une salade froid alors j'ai
mis de l'eau à bouillir
oui je vais la salle et avec du gros sel
toujours pareil on fait ça c'est pas
sorcier
j'avais peur de n'être alors en point
des pâtes les nouilles dans les
papillons c'est faible parce que sa
compagnie nous y font du bio cru voilà
depuis houston on s'était défait de
macaronis plus tôt voilà alors si on
veut faire des économies d'énergie parce
que rihanna ait tout économiser on
attend que l'autre bout oui et quand
l'eau bout et mais un torchon dessus on
le prie gentiment voilà la save à
rambouillet ça va pas tarder je prends
tout mon temps pour que ce soir vous
oubliez le bien sûr je le plie en quatre
coins est ce que c'est bien c'est pas
mal pour qu'il soit bien là qu'il ne
voulait pas brûler au serbe où je vais
remuer pour pas que ça ça qu'il fait pas
cas d'accord le pardon je bafouille jeu
mais n'en torchon comme ça bon couvercle
oui et je t'aime et on attend huit
minutes avant de regarder ce qui se
passe est là car au bout de huit minutes
on regarde si on le veut à la vérité
c'est la mode maintenant un peu taquin
ça suffit on les écoute ans les
personnes qui souffrent tous très bien
et sur les vrais moi je les aime bien
cuites et bien mollement toujours à
l'envers on est un petit peu plus
toujours avec l'auteur choi couvert
toujours à l'intention d'un couvercle
sardon du normalité que c'était une
recette un petit truc bordelais puis
voilà
avant de l'emporter grâce à la méthode
alors pendant que ça se passe c'est une
minute on va peut-être s'occuper de quoi
de la société
de la saison de vente de cette pâte et
qu'allez vous mettre plein de petits
trucs qu'ils ont le bon goût
c'est à dire deux troncs de l'oignon
blanc céleri carottes poivrons et
l'estragon l'oignon de lady et du poivre
mais elle est dure voilà et comment
faites vous france inter europe
maintenant sous vêtements voilà on va
faire un petit air de chaque truc
salois les lâches croisés oui je crois
quand même voix la valeur assemblée
puisque je me demande si si le poivron
ça sera eh bien ça va très vite
bien très vite très vite damion voilà
c'est bon pour l'audit et je regarde un
peu agréable de vous habiller parce
qu'on va pas faire une salade pour 10
personnes
il a alors quelque chose de couleurs et
des 20 mètres poivron vert
voilà ça c'est un petit peu moins facile
de manier rien fait du tout petit
morceau poids oui ça doit aller je crois
mais aussi oui parce que manger ou
l'agent de smith a fait les tout petits
morceaux se fait jeter comme peu non
c'est bon la barre alors maintenant la
fenêtre un peu de remue ouvrir le jeu le
coupé ce sera plus facile puis on ne va
se mouiller pas comme ça pas mal et
gaspillent a tous voila vous allez le
rap est aussi c'est quand j'étais à
l'école oui bon on me dit aujourd'hui le
gaspille pas ne jette rien
alors moi la bonne éducation de
batteries sont moindres et reprendra
tous les enfants on ne jette rien en
cuisine
cela passe d'être méthodique et de faire
les choses bien c'est joli toutes ses
couleurs est bon délicieuse de tout ça
c'est du bon goût alors le rouge d'un
petit peu de rouge et bien l'estragon
comment est ce que vous le préparez à
l'estragon jeune couple aux ciseaux oui
parce que ça vous en rappelant ce n'est
pas le rappeler ce serait une
catastrophe
et comme il est bien essayé ça va être
facile ans a lu un petit peu l'a rappelé
à la table mais l'assiette elle est
faite pour ça c'est pas grave
oui ça nous fait un joli jardin
alors ça on le coupe tout simplement se
veut vous rêvez dit que c'était un
assaisonnement en fait c'est un choix de
petits légumes râpés il va falloir
assaisonner avec quelque chose
qu'est ce que vous allez verser dessus
avant de jouer m de céleri faut pas
l'oublier
pourquoi qui va se rappeler aussi
celui-là
attention le parapet vaudou avec ça fait
mal avec une petite frappe comme servat
nallet y en a c'est parce que ça se fera
oui et comme je suis pas très fort mais
c'est pas ça qui vous fera gros si vous
avez sur ceux des légumes comme ça c'est
bon pour vous là alors 29 vais mettre du
vinaigre vin de noix
ça doit devenir très bon à la soie brute
de tout ça ça va cuire lui les cuire les
là et vous mélangez les verts je vais
mélanger le tout devient l'affairé que
j'avais à faire de ces petits tas oui
mais ce que j'en ai vu comme ça
n'avançait oil et vous allez laisser
macérer quelques minutes oui et après on
va les regarder nos pattes
vous les avez sorti parce qu'il faut les
laisser refroidir maintenant puisque
qu'une salade c'est vrai on sera donc
assez froid alors que si on se réfère la
mayonnaise
alors ça j'espère que tout le monde
c'est là c'est quand même un et avait de
la motor de personnes de rentrer mais
lyonnaise est quand même c'est assez
meilleur sur l'as fait soi même
bien qu'on en trouve de très bonnes
n'est pas pareil ça n'a rien à voir
et quand on a la chance d'avoir des jeux
bien jaune comme hirian de votre village
voire attendue du sel du vinaigre de
noir un tout petit peu une paire à 4 et
voilà de la moutarde 2 cuillères à café
chanter de d'oise ornent la loupe pas et
maintenant on ajoute lille peu à peu
sous l'averse où ça va rentrer et on
tourne en rond
il faut que ne soit pas conduire là
contrairement aux autres maillons elle
vous paraît bien et les fluides et les
jolies pour moi ça va et alors qu'est ce
que vous faites
on va tous venir on va tous mélangés
évidemment voilà alors là les pattes qui
sont en gros ce qu'en dit il tous ses
petits légumes qui sont mélangés
on m'a serré je vous donnais mon nouveau
plates bien sûr et alors cette
mayonnaise liquide
tu vas finir le tout ça va faire une
entrée facile facile de conduire
j'emmène tout regarder ça et si on peut
même la faire faire par les enfants
c'est tellement facile sur où on envie
d'en manger ça vous va leur messagerie
c'est superbe et le plat principal ou
est ce qu'il en est
non répond plus et ben c'est l'apothéose
elle est belle alors ça à quelle
merveille c'est amazing la pétition ça
j'avais ça roule à vive allure et sa
guise dans sa serre doit être bon un ce
maïs regarde l'année tout temps là se
joue mais mille hectares entre ce légume
extra la stabilité sur place a fait
accompli eh bien je crois que si vous
avez envie d'essayer on ne fait pas plus
facile
la salade de nous il ya quand même c'est
enfantin et délicieux est bon et pas
cher vous la préparez juste avant de
passer à table entre et essayer au
revoir bientôt
au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]